le recrutement est en cours depuis
plusieurs jours après avoir signé une
convention avec le dispositif écogardes
la commune de ben souhaitent s'investir
davantage dans la préservation de
l'environnement et recherche son futur
éco garde communale c'est la première
ville des yvelines à franchir le cap ça
fait plus d'un an que je travaille sur
le sujet
j'avais quand même de bonne espérance
mais aussi vite je crois c'est pas et là
je suis très très fier il chemin tout
seul est très fier de mon équipe aussi
qui est derrière qui est très fier ça va
aller dans la continuité ça va
pérenniser le
voilà le poste l'idée et puis ça
empêchera pas qui est toujours ce
système bénévoles loin de là on sera
toujours là mais du coup ça va appuyer
comme le disait ma rivale fait tout à
l'heure voilà c'est ça fait aussi des
contacts aussi plus fixe pour pour un
ensemble de choses et d'action en
complément de la police municipale
l'écogarde agira surtout sur tout ce qui
touche à la protection de la nature si
son rôle est avant tout de sensibiliser
et de valoriser les espaces naturels de
la commune il aura aussi la possibilité
de verbaliser les incivilités l'écogarde
dans le dispositif il a une de ses
missions c'est surtout aller au contact
des gens et c'est vraiment un ensemble
entre la
on a de la surveillance on sensibilise
les gens ont fait beaucoup de pédagogie
aussi voilà c'est beaucoup d'appels
publics et puis dire aux gens ce qui se
passe à faire ce qu'on ne peut pas faire
s'ils pouvaient déclencher au niveau du
département alors là bravo il ya
d'autres communes ont des conventions
mais n'ont pas forcément un personnel
qui sera embauchée spécialement pour ça
vous formez % nous on à la police
municipale on a un des postes qui a été
réservé pour ça sur quatre en fait c'est
qu'on montre la volonté selon le nouvel
éco garde aura aussi pour mission d'être
le référent en lien avec les brigades de
gendarmerie dans le cadre du protocole
jantes vers cet outil de discussion en
ligne permet notamment aux élus de la
commune de signaler des dépôts sauvages